good Eve
and welcome to the 8th annual Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
governor's Awards tonight is an
opportunity to remind us what we love
about movies not just the fact that they
can entertain and enlighten us but how
in uncertain times they can connect us
change us and unify us
and tonight is our opportunity to honor
those whose careers have transformed our
industry and set new standards of
excellence we honor them for they have
touched us beyond measure but we do so
knowing that one day they will hand the
baton to other remarkable talents some
of whom have not yet even been born at
the academy we are committed to
empowering that next generation of
creative talent and ensuring that next
generation represents the real face of
America and the world and that is why
inclusion isn't just a favor we're doing
for anyone it's a strategic imperative
for our industry
despite what the press may tell you it
isn't about a magical algorithm typed
into a search engine it is names not
just numbers substance not justice
statistics bringing new voices and new
faces into the room and making sure they
are heard and seen and it's about change
top to bottom and that change is
underway and thanks to your hard work
and support the progress we have made is
being noticed around the world but even
with all that has been accomplished
that's not enough for us we're not to
the mountaintop yet but we can see the
peak up ahead we can't get there without
you so I ask you tonight to help us
chart that new course to find talent and
lift it up to higher to recruit to
mentor and never ever to give up on the
promise of taking a shot on the new kid
the way someone took a shot with you to
that end
to that end the Academy brought together
the cornerstones of our industry studios
distributors guilds production companies
all of you in this room to launch the
Academy's talent development and
inclusion program which will create
paths and opportunities for students
into our industry and with our doing
that we will reflect the face of the
world and the audiences we hope to share
our art with all over this planet ask
any writer any director any actor and
they'll tell you that the heart of
moviemaking is all about perspective
whose point of view is being represented
what do you see through the camera lens
who is behind the camera itself imagine
the difference it will make when we open
our industry to reflect the complete
mosaic and diversity of our world of our
world the movements and conversations it
can trigger and that's our mission
to find the next Jackie Chan the next
envy coats the next Lin stall master and
the nets Frederick Wiseman
what an amazing standard tonight's
honorees have already set for our
industry you'll hear much more about
each of their individual accomplishments
throughout the evening but for now let
me say this about what tonight's
honorees have in common they inspire the
next generation with the same sense of
wonder and enchantment that first
touched all of us as kids they lift up
so many each time they share with the
world through the power of film new ways
of looking at our world and they believe
that art creativity conscience
conviction telling your story and
knowing that someone somewhere will see
their own reflection in your vision that
remains as powerful as it was a hundred
years ago when the first film was made
in California and so a toast to our
honorees jackie and lynn frederick on
behalf of the Board of Governors and the
entire Academy congratulations
Cheers